I would argue that the biggest issue in
the world today is the weaponization of
fear politically parenting I think
parents using fear to parent the way
they choose to is actually creating a
lot of vulnerability in children and is
the reason for anxiety at scale and I
would argue that in corporate in
business bosses that use fear instead of
humility which triggers safety is the
missing trait of the majority but can I
ask you like how do you define a high
performing team and how do you measure
it
I measure you know how do I Define how
to measure I I Define it based on how I
measure it I think that for me a high
performing team starts with retention
I basically the only more than
even how much money we have in the bank
I care more about how long are people
staying at the company on average
so for me a high performing team is
first based on retention
um which is just black and white math on
the gray side the non-measurable
I use my intuition
on how happy are the people some people
stay in jobs because of money that is uh
often a gateway to unhappiness
and so it's not just retention it's it's
overall Common Sense slash intuition
slash emotional intelligence to get a
sense of how happy are they while
they're here
and then finally
um
I I judge performance or or know how
it's a high performing team based on the
results you know for all the warm and
fuzzies I'm sure you sensed this in the
book that I wrote for all the warms and
fuzzies and la la and all this if you're
you know in that book are words like
tenacity and ambition and uh and I I
think work ethic matters and and I think
results matter I I think that so much of
the world's unhappiness and anxiety is
based on the fact that we eliminated or
demonized competition at the Youth Level
the idea that eighth place trophies are
a good idea is a huge mistake in my one
person's opinion and so the other way I
recognize if there's a high performing
team is if they're winning and in
business that means they're hitting
their financial goals both top line
revenue and profit for me not only do I
measure success financially Top Line and
below line revenue in a year I try to
look at it in a three five seven year
window thus giving and this is important
to hear thus giving a team the ability
to over focus on happiness and retention
in a given year that may actually hurt
them on their Top Line and bottom line
revenue but if I look at the body of
work
I'm always building businesses in
perpetuity you know we talk all about
building brand which is a marathon right
let's build a brand yet you know this
everybody here knows this the business
operators from the CFO down
uh care very much about sales
and we do many things to hurt our brand
in the face of hitting numbers and sales
because we are in corporate environments
held accountable to stock prices what's
great about running private businesses
is
I'm I went three I mean I've only been
running Boehner for 14 years there was
three years where we barely made a
profit
it was it was I was transitioning we
were growing up I wanted to try some
things I made a lot of mistakes we had
some casting issues uh we had some
product Market fit issues
but
you know had I been a publicly traded
CEO I might have not been able to make
it to that fourth year in the window
that I'm referring to which ended up
being our highest profit year ever
and so
you know for I think High performing
teams look different in different
environments in the private sector where
you have more time I think you can lean
into a lot more of the emotion in the
publicly traded sector you've got to
find a little bit more of a balance
unfortunately and that gives it a bigger
challenge the everybody here can talk
all they want about not about the
results and the reality is we are we are
unfortunately this is what we signed up
for just like athletes they it's a great
thing to be an athlete but when you
stink and don't perform well the media
and your fans destroy you like I did
with my Jets players this weekend and so
you know I think actually I didn't
because I love them so much but uh
punchline is the results matter so Mal
comes the second question which is a
what is your strategy
to and and can you please use the
emotional ingredients because I love
when in the second part of the book when
you use your emotional ingredient
examples
um what would be your emotional
ingredients with your strategy to build
a high performance performing team in a
changing environment because this is I
think it's time facing yes the biggest
challenge it's it's always changing you
know so how what would be your strategy
uh with the ingredients in the book and
in real life which is why I wrote it I
think humility number one I think the
super ingredient the super emotional
Nuance that most Alpha
winning leaders Miss is the power of
humility
for example for me with all the tenacity
and conviction and accountability and
self-awareness all the traits that I
talk about in the book that I have
um conviction I mean one of the reasons
I think I'm able to lead teams is
conviction there's no confusion for my
1500 employees where I'm taking the
company and what I care about
however I think the only thing that
makes me palpable the thing that makes
the whole engine the gas the electricity
the Sun that makes it all work is
humility and I think the biggest thing
for a lot of people watching here is
a lack of humility creates a humongous
Detachment between you and your team
and so something that's just absolutely
not talked enough about whether you
employ two people and have a small
business of three
or you have 800 people in your
department is how significant humility
is because it humanizes you it also
makes people feel safe
when you're willing to admit you don't
know or you messed up it allows your
direct reports and their reports to do
the same creating a much more
emotionally inclusive environment you
know we talk about thank God the world
Now talks a lot more about inclusion
from a gender and race and religion and
things of that nature however
I would argue that the biggest issue in
the world today is the weaponization of
fear
politically
parenting I think parents using fear to
parent the way they choose to is
actually creating a lot of vulnerability
in children and is the reason for
anxiety at scale and I would argue that
in corporate in business
bosses that use fear
instead of humility which triggers
safety
is the missing trait of the majority I
think he does one part of your book you
talk about your death right remaining
the the the wine business and you talk
about that really right so how he
actually had the culture and how he
perceived the managing in the older
times and right now so what is the
difference so it cannot touch base what
you're saying right my father was born
and raised and lived the first 22 years
of his life in the Soviet Union which is
a communist country
uh where everyone stole from the
businesses because the businesses were
government owned and the only way the
human Spirit could get forward was to
take the enormous risk of significant
jail time to steal and yet almost every
citizen in the country did so
and so you can imagine how dire that was
that led my father to not trust anything
or anybody in any shape or form
so when he came to America and started
his own business
when I was 14 years old we lived 45
minutes from my dad's liquor store and
the first time I ever went to my dad's
liquor store to work he didn't say a
word to me the entire Drive
I was yapping because I've been me the
whole time yep yep yep yep he didn't say
a word we pull up to the store and my
dad looks at me goes keep an eye on the
employees they try to steal
so my father had a very different
perspective on his employees and I used
to judge him and be angry at him for it
as I got more mature I became much more
thoughtful and understanding of where he
came from and what it meant and
you know so I have a lot of empathy for
it however I was visceral to be the
opposite not because my father was like
that but because my mother is like that
and I share her DNA and because I saw
the damaging effects of how employees
felt when they were entrusted by
leadership
um and uh and I've you know to that
point in the book I talk about my
inability to be candorous through the
majority of my career until I repackaged
it as kind Candor and a lot of that also
had to do with sharing my mom's DNA
that's a shortcoming of hers shortcoming
of mine and a reaction to my father my
father's incredibly candorous however
he delivers that Candor with a whole lot
of spicy and that's me being very kind
and you know that made me also visceral
to confrontation and to feedback and I
wasn't able to calibrate it these things
all very much matter in the evolution of
a leader of a boss
and uh yes I'm very affected by my
childhood and and really I'm the
byproduct of my childhood like anybody
else at 14 years old I worked in a
retail store by the time I was 18.
I spent on thousands thousands of hours
on on the store floor watching customers
engage with products and I managed
people since I was a teenager and so you
know here I am 30 years later 46 years
old and I'm a consumerist
and I'm a deeply passionate emotional
intelligence leader and uh and I'm very
grateful for my circumstances
thank you
thank you for sharing and I think you
know you touched Facebook can I answer
something that Daphne how do you
evaluate new candidates in your
interviews on humility and conviction
Daphne I'm going to throw you an
interesting one Mike I've hired tens of
thousands of people at this point in my
young life
um I have outrageous intuition I mean
the first three companies I invested in
in 2006 were Facebook Twitter and Tumblr
I've been very right of the trends and
and and the individuals that I've you
know
picked to be stars of the world I've got
it right I've got it
comma
the amount of times I've hired people
and was downright wrong is staggering
so I I can tell you that the interview
process is one of the most challenging
processes to make a good call
so I've adopted and implemented and have
watched other companies scale this
advice I hire fast I don't overthink it
because I know there's a 50 chance I'm
going to be wrong so I might as well go
fast because the time is valuable
I fire faster
if I know something's wrong and
sometimes that's within a week by the
way
we we invest in being cordial and
empathetic but we acknowledge and we
Candor now we do that well but somebody
could be here for three or four months
and be out the door if it's really wrong
we just know and then finally and this
is the biggest mistake Corporate America
makes
I promote faster
higher fast
or faster
promote fastus
just like you know when something's
wrong you know when something's right
and the amount of times I've tapped on
the shoulder even if you don't promote
there's kids that work in my company
that I I hit up somebody yesterday and
literally he came in the office in a
meeting and I just grabbed him before it
started said hey you're doing a good job
I see it and so um
that's how I think about it how many
people know in their soul that the
concept of feedback
is often a disguise for people to be
political or even occasionally nasty
to me the problem with feedback and the
problem with you know Candor has always
been that it actually creates a
framework for the worst of human
behavior
right and so one of the reasons I stood
up this concept of kind Candor I have
been blown away by just the word kind in
front of Candor as a principal at
vaynermedia and vaynerx how much that's
verberated to a couple of very
interesting things you may think it's
most impacted people
being nicer when they give feedback as a
matter of fact in our company it's
allowed more people to give feedback
many many people
struggled with telling their friend or
acquaintance or someone they liked
working with proper feedback when it was
just feedback but as soon as it was kind
Candor they could say Andrew I love you
you're a wonderful person hey on the you
know the way you videotape like those
are those are real things and so I think
that
putting an adjective
that speaks to a positive human element
in front of something like Candor or
feedback or reviews actually changes the
dynamic aggressively and almost brings
if I use a political analogy it almost
brings the blue and the red more towards
a purple
and so you have the people who are too
kind and can't give feedback kind Candor
Pleasant feedback all of a sudden allows
them to do it and you also confine and
and really put on notice to people that
use Candor or radical Candor or feedback
um as hey this is not your chance to
suppress this person because you're
scared they're going to take your job
this is not your chance to be a little
nasty because you don't like the their
political views or you know and so I
actually think that is a very big deal
okay and what about the one we receive
what you believe that should be do you
think it's the same the same emotional
ingredients that we should practice
ourselves because of course of course if
if look at what we've talked about today
if you're on the receiving end of
feedback and you start with humility you
can handle anything
I'll give you an example I have an
ungodly amount of followers in social
media I post as much as anyone on Earth
I I post on every platform LinkedIn to
to tick tock on LinkedIn the reply might
be because I have radical marketing
views for Corporate America but I think
they're absolutely right in Corporate
America is radically confused but I may
post something and you may get a very
traditional
uh marketing Professor or a very
traditional marketer
be belittle me in the comments on
LinkedIn an hour later I may post on
Tick Tock and do something cool but I
might have a 15 year old say get off of
tick tock old man right and so if I did
not have humility
okay in understanding yeah I understand
a lot of things have gone well for me
but comma who really cares and at the
end of the day far more special people
than me have passed away we give them
roses for 24 hours and everybody besides
their family moves on with their life
right
I mean we're we're a couple hours away
from people for not thinking twice about
Queen Elizabeth she she was the queen
for 70 years
70 and I'm telling you I know this world
it's what I do for a living 24 hours and
it's gonna go into the backdrop right so
who am I and so I think when you're
getting feedback from your boss saying
hey you don't have enough tenacity or
hey you need to be more thoughtful of
your marketing or hey you're not strong
at supply chain or hey
don't get mad at them
deploy humility and say is there any
truth in this I have been uncomfortably
professionally successful for 25 years
a 15 year old kid will leave a comment
and say I'm wrong about something and I
think about it for a half a second to
make sure that I never get too high on
my own Supply my own success
that humility allows me also to deal
with accolades this is a very important
Nuance of humility humility is helping
me when everyone tries to [ __ ] on me
but humility actually helps me even more
with my popularity now when I post
something I get a hundred people that
leave a goat Emoji greatest of all time
I actually argue that humility is
helping me more with that because if I
actually believed that I would become
audacious complacent
potentially unbearable to be around and
and those are far more uh disgusting
traits that I'm not interested in I
think humility
needs its day you know it's funny I
started a wine brand years ago called
empathy wines it's right there
I started it
many years ago six five years ago or so
and at the time
the word was not was not necessarily if
you look at the Google Trends
was it was out there but it wasn't
really popular
obviously there was a lot of tension
racial political tension in the U.S and
the word started to populate and a lot
of my friends were like how did you know
and I said because I do market research
I read my comments I read my DMs I think
much like humility excuse me much like
empathy five years ago I have a real
belief that over the next decade
humility will become one of the most
important conversations amongst parents
and teachers
um and people that genuinely care about
Humanity I believe it is one of the
secret ingredients to far more success
um I think when you lack it you're
exposing insecurity I think insecurity
leads to Great unhappiness
and I'm looking forward to that mature
conversation and I know
to have your employees engaged and you
know kind of still having their child
um things right so
um
what I something I call multiple
dictatorship
so
I
I'm a private company with no board
and so this is a dictatorship like right
I think that's a very aggressive word
and I use it more for tongue-in-cheek
and everyone laughs but the reason I
call it moldable is I have very deep
convictions of how I see the world I'm
sure for the people that have never met
me before even in this first 30 minutes
so like I think he believes in what he's
saying it's very in me
um
I the way we manage it is a couple ways
this is very interesting I hope this
helps somebody I believe the reason it's
working for me and what and more
importantly I don't like using a focus
group of one one of the reasons I
started Vayner was to work with many
companies at this point we've worked
with a thousand plus over the last 13
years in significant ways
uh first of all it's all human a global
company is immediately in cpg land in a
very own vulnerable spot based on who
they're going to give the brand power to
to make the subjective creative calls
so if the global team is making the
creative call the local team is
frustrated the way that works only is
when the global leader and the local
leader have Humanity towards each other
to work it through
right right yeah so first of all to my
dictatorship every leader that has
cross-functional potential political
crossover where decisions have to be
made in my world that is office leads
versus discipline leads right the head
of creative Rob is here but you know
Daisy who runs emea and Vijay who's the
head of creative there may have a
different point than Rob my thing is if
there is a problem
I need to get involved if you are unable
to resolve it and I need to get involved
early not you need to drag it because
then you're not going fast right then
it's politics so it's a dictatorship of
how we operate when cross this when two
departments who are in the same game
don't don't get along
or don't agree
a if they don't get along that
immediately is something we attack
cutting out cancer is the most important
thing you should do in a body when two
people in an organization don't get
along that is Corporate cancer
so that's HR Real Life Humanity all the
good stuff B if it's actually just
beautiful we have something going on
right now with one Global office and one
discipline lead it's actually beautiful
I'm watching it from afar they're not
even I'm not even sure they know I'm
paying attention they're actually being
overly cordial to each other they have
different points of view and they're
trying to over appease and be good it's
a beautiful thing but we need to go fast
I mean I can't wait six months for you
guys to over nice each other so we need
to get the business so I need to get
involved we call it the Supreme Court
when two people can't get to the right
place they come to me we have a supreme
court meeting I make a decision and
everybody moves forward I think that is
scalable because companies that are even
Fortune 500s they have CEOs they have
cos they do and that's what people
should be spending their time on number
two and more importantly than what I
just said the number one way you scale
this is you as a leader the CEO
she or he can pick the players
but she can't tell them what plays to
run let me say this nice and slow the
reason things work for me is I am not
over analyzing what they're doing as
long as the train is moving I believe
that I get to pick the head of APEC I
put Gabby the head of our lat ham I
picked Gabby I hired Gabby to run Vayner
latam right
I don't need to be in her business every
hour on the hour I don't need to have
her over communicate to me if she's
hitting her I picked her I'm gonna let
her breathe you get to pick the person
but then let them breathe
that's right trust is imperative it
makes people feel safe you also have to
give them time
you know and so I think that from the
top of leadership you get to pick the
people if I don't like what Tim's doing
in aipac I can fire Tim
so it's accountability at the top of
picking people creating a couple of
simple rules to allow people to play
well with each other and then
understanding everything is your fault
accountability if everything at Vayner
everything at Vayner is my fault
because if somebody's not doing it well
I was the one who hired them and if I
didn't hire them directly I hired the
person that hired them
full accountability so they said how do
you make sure you're listening to the
voice of your employees you mentioned
retention is very important to you do
you have a strategy or formal channel
for your employees for your feet provide
feedback Sylvia
it's not a system it's not an Excel
sheet it's not a form it's not a review
cycle it's a culture
do we have a formal Channel yes it's
called an incredible environment of
happiness and kindness and kind Candor
that allows people to feel comfortable
to talk to each other we had a thousand
person all Hands-On
Andrew I don't know if you saw this the
other day last one or two Hands-On all
hands on thousand people while I'm doing
I'm in the middle of my presentation and
the chat's always running fast and
Vayner because they know I love it like
you can tell here today so it's going
fast there's a lot of them they feel
comfortable it's not uh overly corporate
and an employee who'd only been here for
six months in the chat said Gary I'm
upset with you you canceled our meeting
yesterday
stop me abrupting them I stopped dead in
the middle of the presentation said I
need to address this I'm so sorry you
know given what I do for a living
occasionally AKA every day Three Fires
come up and I'm really sad that I
canceled and you will get it we'll get
it rescheduled the amount of senior
leaders who'd been here for less than a
year that worked in agency world for 10
15 years that reached out to me and were
just flabbergasted
that that was the response that I even
addressed it that that's how I addressed
it
and so it's culture
I love how people are like well we have
a system for that a system is only as
good as its culture
people like we have a handbook I'm like
words are taken into context America has
a constitution I don't know if anybody
heard on here people read it differently
the Bible is interpreted differently the
Torah is interpreted differently the
Quran is interpreted differently the
Constitution the Bill of Rights
these [ __ ] [ __ ] handbooks and
[ __ ] manifestos that companies have
are pillars they're only as good as the
way you act within them
otherwise they're just [ __ ] words
often used to weaponize fakeness your
companies will have kind of high
performance right so who really want to
work with you and really high
performance how do you manage their
expectations
the expectations of whom
high performance
with it ah you mean how do I that's a
very good question how do I manage the
expectations of my highest performers
very carefully
this is a very good question
um
the way I do it is if someone is truly a
high performer and I believe you've got
to cut that off at scale somewhere in
the basis of one to two percent of the
employees to do what I'm about to tell
you there's other ways but this is what
works for me number one
High touch
constant texting
constant meetings High touch
if you're ever detached
communication Wise from your top
performers you're dead
so number one religion in my number one
religion
High touch wildly engaged
back to family dinners with the plus
ones
right all of that that's number one
number two over communication to make
them feel it's a big one over
communication to make them feel safe to
change their mind of their Ambitions
this one's going to be a curveball I'm
excited to see the comments
the number one thing I've recognized in
the last 25 years of managing people
about high performers is their North
Stars change
so a 24 year old who's come in here two
years in and completely dominated May
sit down with me and she may tell me
that she's going to be the CEO of the
whole company one day and I get excited
I go good because I'm old and I can't
wait for someone to take over and we
laugh
sometimes that 24 year old at 29
finds their life partner
and all of a sudden she and he's not in
the office 15 hours a day every day
and and they're not going down the path
of becoming the CEO anymore
and I'm very conscious of that first of
all don't forget what I said High touch
so I'm paying attention
and either I if they sit on it too long
or they tend to bring up like hey you
know I think I need a little more
work life balance and I'm like Mazel Tov
amazing I I don't need you to be the CEO
you wanted to be the CEO you're gonna
work your face off let there be no
confusion there is no other way
and back to the earlier question that's
too big of a price for some people with
family others figure out how to manage
it and everything in between everyone
has their own situation but
the the realities with high performers
is allowing them room to change their
mind number three
understanding the balance between praise
and truth and candor
a lot of times people are concerned are
over complementary of high performers or
disproportionately under complementary
depending on what strategy they're
deploying
many people try to pick at the
shortcomings of their High performers to
keep them in line
others try to over verbalize
to keep them in line because they give
them positive reinforcements but they
can't afford maybe the financial or the
title things that the person's and so
and the truth is you've got to find the
middle it's got to be based on the
actual truth
and people struggle with that because
they're using one or two or both sides
of the equation of what I just said so
for me it's
a lack of fear of losing them
it's a you know it's a deep
commitment to an actual relationship
above and beyond the professional one
it's
over communicating with them when you're
not going to deliver on what they want
Gary I need to be a senior vice
president this next race cycle
let me sleep on it three weeks later hey
I think it's gonna be an extra cycle and
here's why and I always say this hey I'm
making a subjective decision I might be
wrong
I'm in the unfortunate position to have
to make that subjective decision
and you have a Humanity Humanity
Humanity
Humanity's missing I love that
that's beautiful thank you you're
welcome here Ted Ted M says what do you
think about the quiet quitting Trend Ted
I think there's a much bigger Trend that
nobody's paying attention to which is
the never applying in the first place
trend
okay
if you talk to the average 16 to 22 year
old they are uncomfortably aware
that making fifty thousand dollars a
year
seventy thousand dollars a year selling
stuff on Facebook Marketplace or eBay
making Google AdWords doing small brand
deals on tick tock
companies are gonna have a tough time
getting people in for under 100K when
there's so many goddamn options for
these kids to make money on the internet
these kids are not growing up with the
world we grew up with
and so we we [ __ ] on gen Z for being
entitled and lazy and what they're being
is thoughtfully understanding of their
options
that's interesting so I believe you have
to provide Extra Value I'm sitting in a
room with Andrew who's filming me I know
how much Andrew makes I know where he's
in his life cycle he's investing in me
and the opportunity
it's not just a job he's making a bet
too he he saw what happened to the
people before him it gives him
confidence that it's about worth taking
we as companies are going to have to
come up with Concepts that enable these
youngsters to make a bet worth taking
because the alternative is more
interesting
and I can tell I have a 15 year old he
does garage sales because of you I'm
very humbled and by the way what excites
me about that is the reason I want 15
year olds to garage sale is first I want
more 15 year olds to stand in their own
two feet and buy things with their own
money not their parents money because
that will lead to a lot of Happiness
number two garage sailing teaches a lot
of things it teaches work ethic because
if you're going to get the good stuff
you got to wake up at 6 a.m it teaches
marketing if you want your stuff to sell
on eBay you're gonna have to know how to
title it and how to write the copy and
how to put a picture and if you're going
to want to make that transaction you're
gonna have to pack it and go to the post
office and do all this stuff and I'm a
very big fan of garage sale flipping as
a foundation of teaching retail jobs
where you deal with a lot of people or
garage sale jobs where you're learning a
lot of different skills
there's one thing missing which is after
he gets the money yes he does this for
three years
after you get the money what he does
with the money is he is he yeah but you
don't want to be you know what yeah I
just want to say this I'm going to pick
up more questions yes please I was just
going to say to give you some light at
the end of the tunnel I made a lot of
money as a kid trading cards and things
of that nature I was good at saving my
money I I was really tall because we
came from nothing I was taught well but
I bought so much dumb [ __ ] you can't
imagine when you're a kid you're a kid
when you're 15 you're 15 and you know I
had a lot of things going for me DNA
wise circumstance wise parenting wise
and I still did plenty of silly things
thus rendering me incredibly empathetic
to every child on Earth you're 15. I'm
gonna end with one thing even though I'm
late and I can see them hovering but
Alice asked somebody something really
cool first she was very sweet Gary
you're impressively articulate do you
have any recommendations on how to
improve communication skills
I I've thought a lot about this lately
because I've come to realize in my older
age I'm like oh this is actually my
superpower like jeez this is this was it
it was the communication both publicly
privately all of it which is why the
kind Candor thing was so humbling it was
my biggest weakness it was my kryptonite
um
for a long time publicly I'm great you
can see I'm very candorous here and I
was doing that consistently but not
privately because it was I didn't want
to hurt people's feelings and I worked
on it but
I've got a very good answer for you
Alice it's based on fear the reason I'm
the reason I was not good at Candor or
clear my communication was I feared
hurting feelings of people I liked
and loved
um in in in business
um
and in communicating all of it comes
down to where your fear is so many of
you would be dramatically more
articulate if you weren't watching the
words you said with the concern of could
it get you in trouble in the company
I also think communication is incredibly
based on intent I think one of the
reasons we know
the
communicators of love and communicators
of hate Gandhi and Hitler the reason we
know that is that they had very deep
conviction around their intent I think
most people are passive or indifferent
about the words that come out of their
mouth I am deeply passionate about the
Legacy I leave as a human being I think
Gandhi is the same but I also think that
the bad people were the same they had
deep conviction and intent to do damage
to deploy pain to create division
and so I think intent is incredibly
important in communication and I think
um
I think that's it
[Music]